well as you just saw on tape northern
count in favor of
infanticide this week we're not
exaggerating
northern said it slowly and clearly you
just saw it then he reiterated views
just in case he wasn't clear the first
time in a statement today northern
explained that abortion at any stage
is a positive good and this is worth
listening to carefully because
quote reproductive freedom leads to
economic
freedom in other words abortion is
virtuous because it makes women more
efficient
employees better and more dutiful
servants of northern's donors they can
work longer hours
without worrying about anybody but their
bosses northern is in favor of that so
are most prominent democrats they're
serving their own masters
in the private equity class well the
press covered all of this of course but
not the way you'd imagine to the
reporters at the washington post the
real crime here
was republicans complaining about ralph
northam quote
abortion bill draws gop outrage against
virginia governor northam
comma democratic legislators that's an
actual headline
republicans whine too much infanticide
not a big deal
and then all of that changes you heard
on today the first day of black history
month the site called big league
politics uncovered the photo trace just
told us about
what's so interesting about it is that
ralph northam spent
a lot of his last campaign calling his
opponent
racist again and again and again the
closing of that campaign was an
unending flurry of ads putting his
republican opponent
up against pictures of what happened at
charlottesville the atrocities at
charlottesville there was no evidence
that his opponent was
racist but northern said it a lot and
yet strikingly northern's opponents
never took pictures of himself in
blackface or in a clan robe
so there is some irony in this story as
of right now a number of prominent
democrats kamala harris among them have
called from northern's
resignation over this but there are many
in his party particularly in virginia
who are standing by him
those democrats personally oppose
blackface and clan robes as a matter of
conscience
but they don't want them relegated to
some back alley they want blackface and
clan robes to be
safe legal and rare a private matter
between a politician and his donors
for now governor northern will be kept
comfortable you can be certain of that
he'll be resuscitated if that's what his
party desires